la guerre du golfe a été pour l'aviation
d'affaires un véritable révélateur de
ces problèmes financiers mais jets
d'affaires devrait normalement redécollé
après avoir subi ces derniers mois une
baisse sensible sur le nombre d'heures
de vol entraînant inévitablement une
chute dans les commandes d'appareils le
marché de l'occasion a eu tendance à se
développer avec un transfert d'avion
vers les pays les moins riches ou manque
de dynamisme actuel de l'économie
américaine s'est installé un
rééquilibrage des ventes au profit de
marchés nouveaux cas qu'avant c'étaient
les états unis mais maintenant le monde
entier le voyez nord iran l'extrême
orient d'avant du set a eu en australie
au japon
donc voyez d'ailleurs un peu en amérique
du sud donc plus avant qu'un tel
mondiale en attendant la sortie du
falcon 2000 et pour contrer la
concurrence internationale le principal
constructeur français a décidé de jouer
le haut de gamme avec deux types
d'appareils le falcon 50 et le falcon
900 technologie de pointe autonomie de
vol économies de consommation facilité
d'entretien performance accrue au
décollage et pour faure poussé dans le
moindre détail des atouts difficilement
contestable plus de 200 fans paul 50 et
100 vip alcool 900 ont déjà trouvé
acquéreur
c'est vraiment considéré comme un outil
de travail qui libère le dirigeant
d'entreprise des contraintes du
transport aérien tel que des horaires
fixes des escales l'attend dans les
aéroports il est certain que cet outil
est un outil extrêmement puissant pour
épargner le temps et la fatigue des
dirigeants est ce si l'argent est
finalement l'argent ces avions sont
chers mais l'expérience prouve que à
partir d'un nombre suffisant d'heures de
vol dans l'année l'outil est rentable
avec un certain retard les sociétés
françaises ont enfin compris que pour la
prospection de nouveaux marchés elles
doivent se conformer à des déplacements
souple et rapide avec les ouvertures à
l'est et le grand marché de 1993
l'aviation d'affaires a un avenir
prometteur